Let's do some coding to get an idea
of what professor just explained.
Starting with defining our symbols list,
having symbols like SPY,
XOM, GOOG, and GLD.
We then move ahead to
build our dataframe
df just like we did in
couple of lessons before.
So df is our final dataframe.
Now let's start computing statistics.
First we compute mean.
We need mean of stock prices for
each symbol.
And dataframe.mean will do this for us.
As professor explained,
it computes mean for each column.
And our columns denote one stock each.
So we get mean for
all stocks in just one line of code.
So to compute the mean, we just called
the name of the data frame df.mean.
Let's check the output.
Note how Pandas prints the mean for
each symbol properly labeled.
Also, here's the graph with all
the symbols and their data.
Similarly, we can compute median and
standard deviation.
Let's do it.
We compute the median of the data
frame by calling the median function.
Remember the difference between
the mean and the median.
Mean is the average of a set of values
that is the total sum
divided by number of values.
Whereas median refers to the value in
the middle when they are all sorted.
Now let's try standard deviation.
We compute the standard deviation
by calling the function std
over the data frame.
Let's check the output.
Mathematically, standard deviation
is the square root of variance.
But more intuitively, it is a measure
of deviation from central value.
Here, the central value is the mean.
A higher standard of
deviation like here for
Google indicates that the stock
prices has varied a lot over time.